So I've noticed when I've lived in
places rented or owned,
didn't matter then if there were part of
the place,
if there was a part of the place that I
hadn't attended to,
whatever that might mean,
it might meant cleaned.
It might've meant fixed,
but it certainly meant at least
thoroughly investigated.
Then that was chaos.
It was like it was.
It was like the desert.
That part that's,
that's a way of thinking about it.
It wasn't mine.
Even if I owned it wasn't mine.
I had to interact with it before it
became mine and I had to interact with
it and I had to put it in order and then
it became mine and then.
And then to the degree that it became
mine and was in order,
then I was also put an order.
Now you know that because you go into
places that make you uncomfortable and
maybe it's your own house,
it's highly probable.
It's highly probable.
I,
you know,
I walked into.
Well Chinese doctors do this.
Traditional Chinese doctors,
they go into place people's place and
they diagnosed their health conditions
on the,
on the balance of Yin and Yang chaos and
order.
They walk into a house that this is easy
to do.
You walk into a house,
there's too much chaos.
Hey,
you can detect that in no time flat.
Everything is out of order and chaotic.
You don't even want to be there.
You certainly don't want to open the
refrigerator.
That's for sure,
and there are things that should've been
done years ago,
everywhere and every one of those things
is a fight that hasn't happened and
something that's been avoided and you
can't even walk in there and maintain
your health.
As soon as you walk in there,
you're sicker than you were when you
were outside and that's one sort of
place.
And then another sort of places you go
in and you look at the living room and
the person has vacuum.
The living room rug and the lines that
were vacuumed are parallel to one
another and the and the furniture is
covered with plastic and you get a glass
of water and then just as you're going
to set it down on the coffee table,
the person rushes over and puts a
coaster underneath it and everything in
that house says to you that it would be
a lot more perfect in that house if you
were either not there or dead and that's
and that's the message that the whole
house is blasting at you.
And if you happen to live there,
then you're going to be sick and what
you're going to be sick from is too much
order and in the other house you're
going to be sick from too much chaos.
And so when you interact with a house,
the unexplored parts are the chaos that
that parts that you have not yet
contended with are the chaos that has
not yet been transformed by your
embodied logos.
Action into habitable territory.
And it does not belong to you.